Dear Fellow Scholars this is Two Minute
Papers with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
First of all thanks so much for watching
Two Minute Papers. You Fellow Scholars have
been an amazing and supportive audience.
We just started but the series already
has a steady following and I'm super
excited to see that! It is also great
that the helpful and respectful
community has formed in the comments section.
It's really cool to discuss these
results and possibly come up with cool
new ideas together. In this episode we're
going to set foot in computer animation.
Imagine that we have built bipedal
creatures in a modeling program. We have
the geometry down but it is not nearly
enough to animate them in a way that
looks physically plausible. We have to go
one step beyond and define the bones and
the routing of muscles inside their
bodies. If we want them to walk
we also need to specify how these
muscles should be controlled during this
process. This work presents a novel
algorithm that takes many tries to build
a new muscle routing and progressively
improving the results. It also deals with
the control of all of these muscles. For
instance, one quickly needs to discover
that the neck muscles cannot move
arbitrarily or they will fail to support
the head and the whole character will
collapse in a very amusing manner.
When talking about things like this
scientists often use the term "degrees
of freedom" to define the number of
independent ways a dynamic system can move.
Building a system that is stable and uses
a minimal amount of energy for
locomotion is incredibly challenging.
You can see that even the most miniscule
change will collapse the system that
previously worked perfectly. The fact
that we can walk and move around
unharmed can be attributed to the
unbelievable efficiency of evolution.
The difficulty of this problem is further
magnified by the fact that many possible
body compositions and setups exist. Many of which are quite challenging to hold together while moving.
And, even if we solve this problem,
walking at a given target speed is one thing.
What about higher target speeds? In this
work the resulting muscle setups can
deal with different target speeds,
uneven terrain,
and.. hmm..
other unpleasant difficulties.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time!